the planet mercury is named after the
messenger of the roman gods because even
the ancients could see how swift and
fleeting it is in the sky
but it wasn't until recently that
scientists began unraveling mercury's
many mysteries
mercury is the smallest planet in our
solar system
its diameter currently measures just
over three thousand miles about the size
of the continental united states
like earth mercury is a terrestrial
planet with three main layers a core
a mantle and a crust
only mercury's crust has no tectonic
plates
also its iron core is enormous by
comparison making up 85 of its radius
while earth's inner and outer core
account for just 55 percent
because of the cora's exceptional size
it's had a surprising influence on
mercury's overall size
by causing it
to shrink
the hot iron core has slowly cooled and
contracted over the planet's 4.5 billion
years
in doing so it pulled mercury's surface
inward and has caused the planet to
shrink radially by more than four miles
this shrinking planet is also the planet
closest to the sun orbiting our solar
system's star at an average distance of
roughly 36 million miles
such proximity affects mercury's
atmosphere or rather the lack of one it
only has a very thin exosphere which is
traditionally the outermost layer of a
planet's atmosphere
this exosphere is made of oxygen sodium
hydrogen helium and potassium
all whipped up from the planet's surface
by solar winds
the lack of atmosphere and close
proximity to the sun also makes mercury
a planet of extremes
the surface temperature can climb to 800
degrees fahrenheit during the daytime
and fall to 290 degrees below zero at
night
mercury's proximity to the sun is also
the reason behind its age-old reputation
of being swift and fleeting
the sun's gravity pulls harder on
mercury than any other planet and like
all planets mercury travels in an
elliptical orbit slowing down when it's
farther away from the sun and
accelerating as it draws closer
clocking in at an average speed of over
100 000 miles per hour mercury slings
around the sun in just 88 days
from earth mercury is difficult to
observe because it's fleeting and so
close to the sun
and so far it's only been visited by two
spacecraft
nasa's mariner 10
and messenger
those missions gave us much of what we
know today
but future ventures are in the works
with high hopes of revealing
more of mercury's secrets
[Music]
[Music]
you